welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 chapter
the jedi perhaps the most crucial
episode of the series since
its premiere revealing the spoiler
warning a live-action ahsoka tano her
questified grand admiral thrawn
and the name of the child we have been
calling baby yoda
that name being grogu grogo and i can
feel each other's thoughts
kroger grogo grogu grogu
which i assume by now that you know and
already have an opinion about now i made
another video breaking down
grogu's timeline from the events of
order 66 to the moment mando found him
in the mandalorian series premiere and
tommy and i went
into it further in wikileaks but in this
episode i am going to go through this
episode frame by frame to scrutinize
each shot of the episode not just for
the many star wars easter eggs and
tie-ins but for the fascinating
craft details that people make the show
put into it and
yeah before i begin the shirt i am
wearing is our this is away shirt it is
available for a limited time only in our
official merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com actually phillip
knocked out
a brand new shirt to celebrate the
reveal of the child's real name
this has got to be the first shirt out
there that has a little baby grow goo by
his real name
in his adorable little mug shot because
he's a little monster all right here we
go in the episode
the episode opens on corvus the forest
planet bogatan told us about back in
chapter 11. though
instead of the lush uh rivendell i kind
of expected we instead get a charred
mordor landscape which in our wikileaks
after show i interpreted as a symbolic
reflection of the dead
jedi dogma that ahsoka and grogu should
really no longer cling to
the sacred jedi texts the
smokey fog illuminates with the twin
white blades of ahsoka tano played in
flawless cosplay by rosario dawson
though
maybe snips his snips could have been a
bit longer because she's older but oh
well she looks just like her otherwise
bravo in the background sukitano was
introduced back in clone wars and
against apprentice and friend who later
gets falsely accused for a crime by the
jedi order and even after her name is
cleared she
walks from that order and in the final
season of clone wars that came out
earlier this year
she helped poketan liberate mandalore
for a maul but
right as order 66 came out she was
forced to break with her beloved clone
trooper unit ahsoka's cloak here
actually is the same cloak she was
wearing in that series finale ahsuka
also appeared years later in the star
wars timeline in rebels fighting anakin
as vader
with these two white lightsabers that
she actually got from inquisitors
inquisitors were former jedi dragged
over to the dark side and tasked with
hunting down runaway jedi rebels ends
with ahsoka joining sabine wren to seek
out ezra bridger who had previously
zipped away to some unknown destination
the hyperspace whales along with thrawn
more on that in a bit but before i
continue thank you to bessie's shoes for
sponsoring this video
if you are looking for shoes that look
great keep your feet dry and temperature
controlled and are super comfortable
this is the way bessie makes knit
sneakers that are 100 waterproof and
weatherproof they're way more
comfortable than some stiff old winter
boot
dumb boots fessy's shoes are super
stretchy look at that they stretch in
they fit you like a sock they only weigh
175 grams they are made with the space
age dynamex material so these are shoes
that you can wear every day in all kinds
of weather
one less thing to worry about they're
also super easy to clean you really just
rinse with water and toss to the washing
machine besties are sustainably made
with no animal byproducts see baby yoda
isn't the only one thinking green around
here oh
when am i gonna find someone who looks
at me the way mando looks at baby yoda
what the
this is amazing so yeah whether i'm
stomping around naboo or
kicking it back by my pool vestis keep
my feet
dry and they have this incredible cyber
monday deal don't procrastinate and wait
until the last minute to do your holiday
shopping
this is the perfect gift for you and
your loved ones especially for the
upcoming rainy season
get them while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later check out the
link below and if you missed a holiday
sale you can still use my code new
rockstars to get 25
off your vesti shoes ahsoka's lightsaber
action here is so well choreographed i
love how day poloni's direction ids her
position
with just the light of the blades alone
beaming through the merc
similar to the visual that revealed
qui-gon and obi-wan and the poison gas
and phantom menace
a jedi misdirect designed to instill
fear and confusion in her enemies hearts
and it's awesome to see how creative she
gets with these sabers she slices a
trunk and then she cleaves out a whole
piece that she can use to take a guy out
leaving the trunk to drop down on its
lower stump so it's not just saber
against enemy
she uses her whole surroundings the
kaladin magistrate is morgan ellsbeth
played by diana lee ein of santo
daughter of legendary martial artist dan
anasanto and goddaughter 2 the man bruce
lee
so when she kept getting asked about her
master i was like hell yeah this warrior
was trained by the best he'll recognize
her lieutenant lang played by
michael bean star of terminator and
aliens although i wish he had a bigger
role in the show
oh well now this episode is titled the
jedi for ahsoka i was hoping the title
could have been like plural
and or also referring to the child but
translations from other languages show
how they use the feminine article for
the in this case
as mando and the child approach the kid
once again desires that spherical knob
at the end of the control stick the one
that the kid wanted in chapter three and
that mando looked at and remembered that
he still loves his kid he made his true
active love to rescue him i have a
feeling grogu's love of it might go
deeper than just like a mere kid wanting
a toy
maybe it reminds him of some part of his
past like i don't know it could have
been taken to the death star at some
point we will see
a kaladan watchman uses a scanner
similar to the one used by a postcard on
yavin 4 in a new hope and when they land
these
large creatures it kind of matches
silhouette of an atat at at feed on the
barks of the burnt trees in the
background now mando is asked if he is
part of the bounty hunter guild to which
he responds
last i checked which is interesting
because he kind of broke with the guild
rules back in that chapter 3 episode
though he hasn't technically checked if
he's still part of it and he's also
starting to bend the rules of his own
mandalorian code so he really has no
problem reneging on this agreement with
the magistrate we're just seeing how the
only rule that remains sacred to this
character is his love for
the child i love the production design
on the caledon town it is clearly
inspired by
samurai films with feudal japanese walls
these circular towers with their flat
conical roofs and within the city walls
there's all these peasants living in
squalor
with a sharp contrast to the inner
courtyard palace
serene beautiful a bubble of paradise a
classic wealth disparity that you see in
those kind of stories where the wealthy
elite landlords are
completely unaware of the problems of
the people serving underneath them and i
love how later the duel plays out with a
slow
deliberate kendo style fight
choreography a throwback to the slower
sword play of obi-wan and vader that
george lucas originally
based the whole jedi culture on the
imagery may also remind you of the final
duel in the quiet garden between the
bride and over nichi
in kill bill quentin tarantino is also a
lover of akira kurosawa and staged this
battle the same way a raging melee
heightening to
an ice-cold intimate face-off meanwhile
the western counterpart to samurai films
the western film genre inspires a duel
outside the courtyard between mando and
lang with a gunslinger showdown lifted
directly from the work of directors like
sergio leone essentially
westerns and samurai films are parallel
genres just from different parts of the
world
both inspiring the star wars world
it's so amazing to see both play such a
big role in this episode
l smith keeps prisoners on display in
these public stocks with electric fields
zapping them to reveal their skeletons
underneath similar to the zapping sith
lightning that we've seen before and i
believe hera and rebels was
tortured with one of these elizabeth
feeds her fish and her koi pond though
i'm pretty sure those aren't koi in
there notice grogu gives them a curious
look kind of like the frog eggs grogu is
very much into aquatic life just keeping
track of his amphibious origins as we
try to narrow them down
elsmath reminds manda that the jedi are
ancient enemies of mandalore
offering him as a reward for killing
ahsoka a pure bhaskar spear
capable of resisting lightsaber strikes
telling us that mando's armor
is modes away from some ahsoka hits but
also shedding some light on the ancient
jedi and mandalorians
and how they were so evenly matched i
love the ping
the staff makes when he strikes it on
its gauntlet
[Music]
there's an almost magical strength that
you can hear in there that justifies its
ability to
repel a lightsaber hit as they venture
out to find ahsoka amazing easter egg
here the bird on the branch in the upper
left this owl is
mori a hugely significant spirit animal
that follows ahsoka it is the embodiment
of the daughter one of the
three mortis cosmic entities who
represents the light side of the force
the daughter gave her life to
save ahsoka and now she is represented
in this morai bird that bird also
appeared circling over vader in the
final moments of clone wars
ahsoka and mando briefly duel and it is
really fun to see these two one up each
other ahsoka even you can tell gets a
little kick out of it when she looks
down to realize her binds can be
reverted in order to snare mando but
then he mentions about katan sent him
and she sees a child and then
our lives get so much better next scene
framed in the light of the moon
ahsoka and grogu stare each other down
and from this nonverbal forced link she
reveals his name in origin
grogo and i can feel each other's
thoughts kroger
he was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant at the end of the clone wars
when the empire rose to power
he was hidden someone took him from the
temple
and i love how grogu looks up at mando
each time he uses his name but then even
more subtle it gives
a look of recognition when ahsoka
mentions the name of master yoda
why is jedi master named yoda
and yes if you were listening closely
there that was a musical light motif to
the john williams
yoda theme playing underneath ahsoka
says some mystery person took the child
from the jedi temple during order 66. in
yesterday's video i speculated that
could have been yattle whom most of us
assumed to be dead based off of a comic
where vader fights seattle's ghost
but there have been like other mentions
and things like jedi fallen order that
suggest she might still be alive we'll
see
now it could have just been obi-wan
kenobi who did survey that temple in the
aftermath and this could definitely tie
in the upcoming kenobi series others
have suggested
jocasta new the temple librarian who did
die shortly after the events of revenge
of the sith but did have enough time to
save that kid if she could have
i'm also intrigued by the possibility of
mace windu who supposedly
died though nobody was ever found and
there is speculation that he could get a
future spin-off series if the theories
are true that grogu and anakin's
matching birth ears
mean they might be part of a dyad i
could see a scenario where grogu uses
his force healing powers to heal the
wounds on mace windu that were caused by
the counterpart anakin now the stark
burnt landscape gives way to lively
green
in the area where ahsoka trains baby
yoda an interesting reflection of the
life force that these two jedi
are about to tap into ahsoka levitates a
rock to him echoing the way master yoda
used rocks to train luke on dagobah but
then she says this
sense much fear in you a direct callback
to yoda's warning
to anakin and phantom menace i sense
much fear in you
ahsoka fears that training a child with
vulnerable personal connections
will result in the same calamity as her
old friend
anakin whom she calls heartbreakingly
the best of us
ahsoka explains how else this family was
massacred during the clone wars and that
ellsworth used that anger to plunder and
destroy worlds to help build
the imperial starfleet but i don't think
that's her mo now
the fact that she calls thrawn her
master suggests to me that she and
thrawn might be building a
new starfleet that's separate from the
empire maybe an independent order of
thrawn ahsoka and mando team up and she
scales the wall slices that bell in half
notice how she also slices the guard
standing right in front of it
so cool guarding the town are hk87
droids an apparent upgrade from the hk47
from knights of the old republic a look
at
also appears we saw one of these last
season and for many
this is another sign that ezra bridger
could show up at some point they do come
from his home world but when ahsoka
confronts ellsmith in the courtyard i
love how we don't see
ahsoka arrive she's just already
standing there waiting for her it's as
if this showdown was
inevitable a promise delivered from that
opening scene
surrender or face the consequences
when ahsoka ignites her right blade the
wind catches her robe on the ground
it's a nice detail of vfx meeting
practical to suggest the warmth of the
blade could have affected the airflow
there
after a thrilling duel ahsoka drops the
big question
now tell me where is your master
where is grand admiral thrawn so
thrawn was one of the first big things
to come out of the star wars expanded
universe novels he was so popular that
dave filoni later brought him into
season three of rebels originally thrawn
was tasked with leading the empire after
its defeat in battle of endor but in
rebels during the galactic civil war he
is pursuing the crew of the ghost
yes he's last seen disappearing in
hyperspace with ezra so for ahsoka
finding thrawn
means finding ezra unless she already
found them
in these past few years and that perhaps
ezra and sabine could be
dead and now ahsoka just wants revenge
against thrawn
so thrawn is a chiss he is a genius
tactician
skilled hand-to-hand combatant which
might be why else bit calls him quote
master i really do think or at least i
hope that he is now building his
own starfleet independent from the old
guard of the empire or palpatine just
because
thrawn would be such a cooler villain
who embraces the spirit of legends what
people
love about star wars without getting
bogged down in that same old
rebels versus empire conflict that every
generation of star wars
is driven by ahsoka tells bando to take
grogu to
tython and place him on a scene stone so
that he can connect with other jedi
the new hope is that jedi luke skywalker
could sense that and connect with these
characters
maybe with a d h mark hamill or just a
hooded figure with hamill's voice but
the
fear is that darker force sensitive
entities might intercept that call
tython is another element from star wars
legends it was originally the home to
the jedi
order predecessor to the jedi order but
it was brought into
official canon in a force awakens rpg
and then a later novel python is
essentially one of the sacred
jedi sites along with achtu jedha
maybe the ruins where all of this
started in the final moments notice how
ahsoka and grogu exchange the subtlest
nod of respect
very similar to the nod that ahsoka
exchanged with elizabeth to me
this suggests an even deeper
understanding between the jedi than we
realized
maybe deeper thoughts and secrets in
grogu's mind that ahsoka chose not to
disclose demando maybe grogu wants to be
taken to taithon instead of staying with
ahsoka on corvus to try to keep himself
and mando away from ahsoka's beef with
thrawn which is probably gonna get real
nasty
and closer to a path that will intersect
them with good things like
luke skywalker so those are all the
subtle details that i found this episode
but there is so much more to talk about
from
this one episode we're gonna be making
more videos about it in the meantime is
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
ea boss follow new rockstars thank you
for watching i have spoken
[Music]
you